hi everyone uh it's it's so good to be
here on behalf of
all the people that are being helped by
robin hood
um i you know uh got to know robin hood
since i got to know paul jones when
robin hood was basically
a glimmer in his eyes and he would play
basketball with kids down in bed stuy
i was lucky enough to see uh what he
and all the robin hood people have done
to help alleviate poverty in the united
states
in a very uh personal and effective way
and uh be able to be a part of it and
what you're all doing is great so
i just wanted to thank you for what
you're doing and tell you how delighted
i am to be
able to be here and to do my small part
uh
i was asked to talk about uh bubbles you
know
is the market in a bubble stock market
in a bubble what's in a bubble
uh and uh i just wanted to uh
give you some thoughts about that and
i've got about 10 minutes to do it
and so i want to be quick
um a bunch of years ago i started to
think about
well what is a bubble what what do i
mean when i have a bubble because i
watched a lot of bubbles over my
something like 50 years of investing um
and um i i basically think
uh thought there were six things that
made a bubble
in my mind and i'm gonna rattle them off
then i'll
apply them so that you know what i think
first
you know how how high are prices
relative to
the traditional measures of
prices is a consideration for example
you know our pe is high or um
yields uh low and that kind of thing
that's a consideration
but it's not what i mean by a bubble
let's let's say for example you can have
prices high which means uh returns low
and you can have that go on for a very
long time that doesn't mean a bubble
pops so i'm really looking at whether
you get a pop but still
it's an ingredient so for example let's
say if we were to take the bond yields
the bond yields are
[Music]
extremely low levels and so say think
about bonds as having a multiple
the multiples of bonds are you know like
75 times earnings or something depending
on what bond market you're
operating in and so when stocks compete
with bonds
they're competing with low returns
and so it's not unreasonable
to think that the stock market could
have a multiple of
50 times if bonds have a 75 time
multiple why can't bonds and that means
a low return
so that's one of the considerations but
it's not all
the second is prices are discounting
unsustainable conditions so
unsustainable starts to be part of
this picture of a bubble unsustainable
means that by the nature of the buying
whoever is doing the buying and how of
that supply demand
that means that that won't be sustained
and that produces
a correction or price is going down
and then um there's this speculative
element number three
so one of those measures of the
speculative elements is new buyers in
the market they're attracted in
the market you know it's the sort of
thing where you know you go to a
cocktail party and people who are never
involved in the thing
are investing in it and that could be
tech stocks and it could be real estate
and whatever but
you know they're drawn in and that
there's a
big bullish sentiment so everybody wants
not having these things makes you feel
dumb that kind of thing
and then also uh number five on my list
is big purchases uh forward purchases
you know like if somebody's buying
apartments that they don't own
because they think that the apartments
are going to go up or back in the
days where i traded a lot of commodities
i would watch
that those who used commodities would
rather than buy from hand to mouth they
would
get a lot of forward coverage in other
words buy
inventory to protect themselves against
the prices going up and so when they go
from
as we have recently seen in commodities
when they go from
not uh having forward coverage because
prices went down and they kept falling
and they say
i don't want to own it to and then uh it
going up and they say i want to
be protected against it going up that
movement causes a lot of
buying and so on so that's buyers
that have extended those forward
purchases
are an indicator that i use this table
here that i'm showing
shows for the stock market as a whole
those items that you know are we in a
bubble is the stock market in a bubble
well
i apply that basically that framework to
all individual securities and i do that
in a systematic way because
my process is to write down the criteria
to use filters and so on and
and try to see which are in a in a
bubble so
uh there are different different stocks
some are in bubbles it seems to me some
are not in bubbles and the stock market
as a whole
uh is indicated by that table let me
just go to the next chart
so this chart goes back to 1910 and it
shows
the on an indicator of the degree to
which we're
in a bubble you could see that it's
bubbly
and it's not as high as the total bubble
but not not as high as it was in 2000
not as high as it was in 1929 but higher
than it was
in 2007 let's take a look at the stocks
that are in a bubble a lot of stocks are
not in a bubble
according to those criteria um so this
goes back
uh back to 1995 that chart and it gives
you an idea
so this is the first chart is the share
of the top
thousand charts that are uh in a bubble
um
and so it's been about five percent or
the share of the
s p 500 about two percent by comparison
to those in 2000 again not as high
as the 2000 bubble or the 29 bubble
which we're comparable
but higher than 2007 so
let's go to the next chart and this
shows um
with the bubble stocks i put together an
index of those that are bubble stocks
and this shows how they've performed in
relationship to the s p
500 and so you could start to see as
we're
uh breaking down the bubble and um i
believe that that's likely to continue
but uh being in a bubble one of the
things is you know bubbles can
expand and contract and the timing is a
big issue
okay so why are we in a bubble uh this
chart goes back to 1900
and the top chart shows a debt to gdp
the bottom chart in the blue line shows
interest rates and the red line
shows the printing of money this the the
amount of money that
that's going in and so what you can see
is when you have a lot of debt like we
have a lot of debt now
and there's a lot of increasing uh
debt and there's the hitting of zero
interest rates
in both cases there's the printing of a
lot of money
and that's a key element of the bubbles
because
um they have a lot of liquidity uh that
comes
into the market and then there's a lot
of throwing around that money
in terms of bidding up all sorts of
assets so
you could see that red line you could
see how when the blue line hits
zero interest rates 1930
starting in 2008 and since we've had
that movement then you have you see the
largest movement now so
a lot of liquidity a lot of debt
financed
debt monetization makes for a classic
bubble
other items are new ipos with
particularly if they have no earnings
high price to revenue
or in many cases no prospect of of
making money
those are bubble considerations too so
i would say you can't say the stock
market
is in the highest a bubble you can't
even say that it's necessarily
in a bubble you have to distinguish uh
which ones
which stocks are in a bubble or have
been in a bubble
uh from those that are not in a bubble
there are a lot of stocks that aren't
and that bubble is a little bit like the
bond markets bubble so i hope that gave
you a little bit of
flavor of bubbles and how i look at them
and where we are
thank you
you